We've talked about slope and
we've talked about the horizontal and
vertical lines.
So let's bring the two together now.
And let's see if we can find
the slope of this horizontal line,
whose equation it looks like is y = 3.
So like I've been doing, I'm going to
pick two points in this line.
Let's do this one,
which looks like it's -2,3, and
this one, which looks like it's 2,3.
Now to find the slope,
I need to compare the vertical
change to the horizontal change.
The rise to the run.
And when I do that, well, look,
there's no vertical change, none at all.
So the rise is 0, and
I divide that by the run,
which in this case is; 1, 2, 3, 4, 0/4.
So the slope is 0.
So I'm going to give you three lines.
So for each of these three lines,
I want you to identify the slope as
positive, negative or zero.
So you can just enter in either
a plus sign, a minus sign or 0.
And you can do that in
the appropriate box.